Speaker 1: Earlier this week, I talked to you
about how Republican Governor of Florida Rhonda
Santos is in some sense out trumping Trump. And
what I mean by that is that de Santos is like
Trump in that he has this authoritarian kind of
unhinged tendency. He's primarily concerned with
virtue, signaling and self aggrandizement. But
he's different than Donald Trump in that Ronda
Santos is more competent and. This makes him more
dangerous, particularly as he's being thought of
as a possible future Republican presidential
candidate and Rhonda Santurce is now
signing a series of bills. But in particular,
I want to talk about one bill today
that will require it will require that high
school students be taught about the, quote,
evils of communism. The bill will also create a
library that will allow students to learn about,
quote, real patriots who escaped communism and
socialism. It's that insane. Let's take a listen
to what Rhonda Santurce had to say yesterday.
And this is really, really weaponized stuff.
Speaker 2: Curriculum can really provide a guide
to how that should be done. The bill also expands
our previous efforts in civics to add a
requirement for the high school government class
that students receive instruction on the evils
of communism and totalitarian ideologies.
Speaker 1: Now, if you want to make the
case that as a matter of economics classes,
students should learn about Marxism alongside
Keynesianism, Keynesianism and neoclassical
economics. I'm all for it. I took Marxian
economics as an undergraduate student. My
you know, my experience was was fantastic. I got
to learn about it. It didn't convert me into a
Marxist, but it was extremely useful. If you want
to argue that communism as a system of government
should be taught in history, class, in political
science, government, whatever it's called,
within the Florida high school level, I think
that that's a fantastic thing that's different
than mandating propaganda about communism
to be taught. Let's listen to a little more.
Speaker 2: We have a number of people in
Florida, particularly southern Florida,
who've escaped totalitarian regimes, who've
escaped communist dictatorships to be able to come
to America. We want all students to understand
the difference. Why would somebody flee across
shark infested waters, say, leaving from Cuba to
come to southern Florida? Why would somebody leave
a place like Vietnam? Why would people leave these
countries and risk their life to be able to come
here? It's important that students understand that
now as part of this bill, Florida will create a
portrait's and patriotism library so students can
learn about real patriots who came to this country
right after seeing the horrors of these communist
regimes. We actually have folks here today. You'll
hear from her in a minute. And a Bauza, she came
to the United States when she was a teenager
fleeing from Nicaragua when the Sandinistas
brought socialism to that country.
She graduated from the University of Florida.
Speaker 1: OK, so I think that
high school students should be taught
about the history of the Soviet Union,
Cuba, Nicaragua, Vietnam, in
a historically accurate way,
properly contextualized. And that certainly would
include the completely authoritarian debacle that
was a Stalinist Leninism. Why not? Students should
be taught that. But this is mandating propaganda.
This is mandating perspective, plain and simple.
And when you hear that part of this bill,
a piece of the curriculum is Patriots portraits
in patriotism that should immediately set off
alarm bells and the very same Republicans who slam
college and university as liberal indoctrination,
they are now mandating a form of actual right wing
indoctrination to be taught in high school. And
aside from being completely absurd, because this
is a blueprint for for long term brainwashing of
children, this also strikes me as the type of
thing that dissent can later refer to if he
runs for president. Now, don't get me wrong, this
is dangerous in and of itself. You start teaching
kids at a young age to associate communism
with evil and their portraits of patriotism,
which will be, of course, mostly right wingers
or people who, quote, fled communism. You start
associating that with good. This is how you get
them early. This is a quite literal brainwashing,
but it also seems like exactly the type
of thing that DeSantis could later point
to as one of his great moral victories. If
he decides to run for president and say,
look at this thing I did in Florida, and it's
like the perfect virtue signal to many of these
right wingers. Now, for everybody who's
going to email me and say, David, you want
them teaching that communism is good, don't you?
You want them teaching that socialism is good,
that Marxism is good. I am not a socialist.
I am not a communist. I am not a Marxist.
I'm a social Democrat. That's a form of well
regulated capitalism. What I do think, however,
because I value diversity of opinion and teaching
people to think for themselves is that kids should
be taught how various economic systems work, how
various forms of government work and historical,
as well as current examples of each the pros and
cons. What achievements have such systems had?
What? Failures have they had how systems have
become become corrupted and whether certain
systems are more prone to corruption than others?
This is called promoting critical thinking. It's
the best safeguard we have against radicalization
of all kinds. It's much more difficult to
fearmonger successfully as a politician when
people are armed from a young age with the ability
to think for themselves and figure out why do I
believe something that I believe is do I have good
reasons for believing what I believe? That's not
what the Rhondda Santurce bill actually does. It
mandates the teaching of a particular perspective
of propaganda. It's a disaster and it is the very
thing that they decry as they have identified
it. So they say at the college level now,
sometimes they've wrongly identified it, but
now they're trying to do the exact same thing
in Florida. It's absolutely disgusting. Let me
know your thoughts. Is this at all surprising to
you? I'm not surprised that this is what they're
doing. You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
That's okay, man. You do have to spell it right.
D d Pakman on Twitter. Let me know your thoughts.
Not only can you become a supporting member
of The David Pakman Show it join Pakman Dotcom